[Music]  no you probably heard a meet cardi B has  exploded this year with her mega hit  bode act yellow and now her personal  life is going to the next level to know  where the rapper is engaged to offset of  the trio me goes to print on my sleeve  what outfit ain't have been the chunko  he proposed on stage Friday night in  Philadelphia party then took to  Instagram to show off the pear-shaped  sparkler and it is stunning she  seemingly couldn't stop staring at it  posting video after video can't say we  blame her clearly overcome cardi then  wrote this on Instagram to her fiance  quote I'm so emotional I love you so  much thank you for seeing the potential  in me for giving me advice molding and  loving me  she called him amazing and extremely  talented saying she can't wait to spend  forever together  [Music]  you